[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
read this week at the round table of dim
lighting link is wearing sunglasses
well
I'm wearing my Hawaiian vacation glasses
which have a tent that is somewhere
between oh come on there's normal
glasses and sunglasses I mean they're
sunglasses but they're not tinted to the
point where I can't wear them in this
dimly lit room and totally see
everything I need to see of you well
yeah but I'm just saying by there I mean
there's some they're lightly tinted
sunglasses but I'm I'm trying to make
this a part of my life moving forward
because this was my life in Hawaii
on my Maui vacation which I'm going to
tell you all about Rhett
and you dear listener so are you trying
to capture the vacation Spirit into more
of your is that the is that why you're
wearing the glasses or is it like no I
think I'm about I'm going to become a
guy who wears sunglasses inside how
could you tell like Elton John
yeah okay I think I could oh you could
do anything you want to thank you
because I really like these people will
tell conclusions that's all I'm saying I
really like these glasses because
they're big and they're I mean they have
progressive lenses in them I can read
with them
and they're you know they're indoor
outdoor sunglasses
well you've made them that you're
definitely wearing them no yeah they're
not too dark so that you have to take
them off when you come inside but I'm
just acknowledging the fact that it is a
it is a choice did I break your
concentration it is a it is a choice
that you like if we me and you went to a
meeting and there was a guy that we met
with right he was wearing those glasses
inside yeah it would be the first thing
we talked about after we left the
meeting be like oh you wear sunglasses
inside that's what we would do but if if
the other parts of that personality
lined up in a certain way then our
follow it would be but you know what I
think he pulls it off I'm I am secretly
hoping I didn't want to talk about he's
Roy Orbison
if he's Roy Orbison yes why did Roy
Orbison wear sunglasses at all times
well I think it was a I always thought
that he was uh visually impaired and
that was why he wore the sunglasses was
he
um I think he did have some visual
impairment but I I just think that he
was self-conscious about the way he
looked without sunglasses
you know are you self-conscious about
the way you look without glasses is that
what it is I mean I I'm conscious of
what I look like without glasses and I
was constantly reminded of that because
I went on vacation with the older
version of myself
AKA my father does he wears contacts uh
no he has no uh problem he has no
Vision issues prescription that's very
unusual for a 70 year old man I know
wow
and he doesn't have nearly as much gray
hair as I do I got that from so you're
going to tell us all about your your
vacation yeah I am before you tell us
about your vacation we do want to remind
you about the fact that we are doing
good mythical evening again if you
forgot how could you I don't remember
all of it good mythical evening is when
um we take all of the constraints that
we have to have on ourselves off in
order to have you know good mythical
morning you guys got to be like brand
safe and friendly and you got to be able
to do something that like you can put on
YouTube but good mythical evening is if
you take all the right-headedness out of
us and you go Buckwild and you give us
some alcohol that you like to party uh
that's what good mythical evening is
September 1st exclusively on moment
house get your tickets at good
mythicaleating.com there's multiple
packages for pre-show and Good Mythical
More Etc
so I want to tell you all about my
vacation we did go to Maui you know
it I had made a decision to do to do
this trip pre-pandemic and really I
think I trace it all the way back to
your family trip to Scotland where you
took your you took your parents and your
brother and his entire family
hey that really got me thinking you know
I can do a vacation and bring bring some
of my family along too I think that
would I think that would honor them I
think they'd like it so we put an
emotion this plan did anybody break any
bones my debt nobody broke any bones
um
well I mean there was one
injury oh I'll tell you about it
uh we put the plan in motion to take my
dad and Nancy and um so once we started
once we started filming dispatches from
Myrtle Beach and recording that podcast
uh which if you want to listen to his
perspective on our vacation and that
episode of dispatches is already out but
there's plenty of stuff that I didn't
get to talk with my dad about I want to
talk to you about and I can you know
give you some of the inside scoop
that I did that I didn't get to in that
episode okay I got two podcasts I got a
joke yeah this is gonna make your life
difficult this is making my life
difficult but
um
I did I on dispatches I would I kept
saying well Dad if you did a good a good
job I'm gonna take you to Hawaii but
really we wanted to go for years it's
just because of the pandemic we weren't
able to do that right and then also for
like Christy's sister and her husband
and their kids we were like planning
another trip to go to Disney with them
that got eradicated with the pandemic
too and we haven't put those plans Back
In Motion
um but we hope to at some point but just
let me tell you I was telling Christy
yesterday I was like you know what I
think this Hawaii trip
was one of the best vacations I've ever
been on whoa really yeah it was like the
perfect balance of doing stuff and not
having stuff to do you know we we booked
a spot at this at a resort
uh on
Wailea down there in the uh southwestern
part of Maui you ever been to Maui I
have not I've been to the Big Island
into Kauai right well you and I went to
Kauai with our families together many
years ago so I was comparing a lot to uh
Kauai when we when we're like driving
around Maui
um we stayed at a beach resort we stayed
at this spot where it was big enough for
like Dad and Nancy to have a room and
Chris to have a room and then you know
the kids to sort things out so it was
like it was it was a it was a nice spot
we had space and where people could go
and Retreat into their own Zone when you
have a 19 year old and a 17 year old you
you want to be able to give them their
own space yeah so I knew that was key
and then I knew that making plans but
then making non-plans was important and
I think all of that really came to
fruition uh in terms of making this the
perfect balance of just a nice well
needed vacation away are you like are
you looking at your thigh what are you
doing with your hand down you're just
twirling my thumbs around this thing I
thought you were looking at your phone
then I saw your phone there no twiddling
this okay all right she's making sure
I'm still here I just didn't know if you
were into what I was saying oh I'm so
into it you're playing the perfect
vacation I don't know if you're
scratches just the the perfect balance
of doing and not doing
I mean the big question the whole time
honestly was
what is it gonna be like to take Dad and
Nancy on this thing Granddaddy and Nana
but you just said it was the best
vacation so do you think it had to do
with the fact that they were there yeah
that was the big question because people
guests
change your family Dynamic and often
they changed the family Dynamic for the
best I have found that when we tried a
better behavior and when there's a
friend of a one of the kids brings a
friend yes nobody shows their ass as
much you know what I'm saying like
nobody just does something stupid
embarrassing just as a complete [ __ ]
because there's a there's a there's
there's somebody who's not family there
yep so do you think that happened I do
think that was the key to it plus the
fact that Dad and Nancy are super laid
back like they were super happy to be
there they don't add stress to the city
they were along for the ride which is a
lot to say for you know uh aging parents
I I I would think there was no control
of anything energy it was like Hey I'm
gonna treat you guys to coming on this
Voyage with us
you know and you're gonna love it
and then you know by the end the only
thing dad said about the halfway point
was
you think I maybe I could play golf and
I was like well I didn't know if it was
too late dad I didn't say anything like
that up because I don't play golf
honestly I'm sorry if that's a little
selfish but that did work out and as he
talked about on dispatches that was a
highlight for him it's taking Lincoln
golfing
but yeah we I mean we really did have a
good time and it it was a test of our
our relationship to have them there
because you are living under the same
roof of these people uh that you never
live with you don't know how it's going
to be they but they were they were cool
they were laid back they were having a
good time and
so I'm happy to report that it all works
he's still your dad also nine days was
like a generous amount of time so just
in terms of like stipulations really I
was gonna I was planning on 14 days two
weeks is what that is right
so you're ready to come home at nine day
nine I was
yeah hmm yeah
I mean that's probably I I would say
that's pretty typical
when you're in the same place yeah
no we're eating the same breakfast every
day I the breakfast got old it was a
good breakfast like you can nine days
are the same breakfast yeah I I mean
that's obviously these are privileged
problems but I'm just saying at a
certain yeah at a certain point I wasn't
really getting out of bed for the
breakfast you know what I'm saying right
the cool thing about going to Hawaii is
that there's three hours uh behind so
when I decided to wake up it was like
early in the morning there's something I
just I felt this like
superiority of like being up so early on
vacation like seeing this I literally
seeing the sunrise every day the first
what time are we talking about the first
few days just because it was a time
change yeah I mean I get up at 5 30 and
it feels like 8 30.
and like I went out there and did some
paddle boarding
it was a beach right out there and you
could go out there and just get us get
some snorkel gear
and go around this little refish type
area and there were sea turtles right
there dude yeah I've never freaking
snorkeled with a sea turtle did you
touch them because that's a ten thousand
dollar fine I did not touch them I just
looked at them and they were some of
them were like
resting on the bottom just sleeping and
some of them were just like floating and
you could just like swim around them and
they were just like used to it they
didn't care they were happy anyway
there's a pig in a blanket anyways for
paddle boarding not right there
like driving around to other sections of
the island there was
um I saw some people a lot of people
surfing and some people doing some
stand-up paddle board surfing but it
early enough it was calm enough to do
some stand-up paddle boarding but not
really with surfing it that really
wasn't the opportunity right there in in
front of us
but I I gotta
I hate the dog Maui
um it was the beaches were beautiful
and there's but it's just not it's not
the same Vibe as kawaii kawaii was like
it's so jungly and like these like
dramatic Green Mountains just like
exploding out of the ocean everywhere
and there's like sheer drop-offs Maui is
more of like you got this
one there's like two islands that are
kind of connected basically into one
Island
so you can easily imagine how they were
each made by their own volcano but there
was a one inactive
I don't even think you'd call it dormant
it's just over this volcano nothing else
to see here it's a done volcano it's
nowhere near act it's spent Haleakala
that formed the majority of Maui and so
it's just looming in the center no
matter where you drive around you look
and it's like yes there's this clouds
it's like this one mountain volcano that
just goes up into the clouds but it has
to be more Lush than the big island and
there's well I haven't been there but
the big island is like just there's like
very large swaths of it that are just
Barren landscape a lot of it was of Maui
was uh farmed for pineapples I believe
so there was a lot of it that was just
like deforested and so now there's
um you know there's like an old sugar
Plantation and there's like
remnants of where they farmed pineapples
but it just kind of leaves it more of
the focal point is the one volcano it's
not like in Kauai where you're like
driving through these undulating roads
around these like huge mountains it's
just not that type of
a hiking destination place now on the
other side of the Island from us there's
um there's a town called Hana and then
there's this one two-lane undulating
road that you can drive and you
basically takes you to the road the road
to Hana it takes almost all day and I
was reading about that and like
basically marriages die on this road
yeah people get car sick and people get
car sick especially the needles
everybody in the Neil family gets car
sick I mean if I go around three curves
I'm a Christie don't you be on your
phone like the amount of times on any
type of road trip I've had to pull over
and had Chrissy just just open the door
run a few feet and just vomit it's just
like I could I mean I could I could
sketch it with in detail I've seen it so
many times please don't it's so I was
like there ain't no way we're going on
this road to Hana
so that I mean it was it would have a
day of us doing something and then a day
of us chilling out uh day one take a
look at dad
this is day one day one baby this is
within a few hours of us getting to Maui
he's just laying out on a lounger you
realize this is your future sleeping
this is my future actually in many ways
this is your present it makes the same
exact face that you make when you fall
asleep his mouth is open like the
picture you're taking me every time I
was sleeping on a plane he falls asleep
as quickly as you I assume you see that
necklace he's wearing that's what they
give you when you show up like that's
literally how quick he just
he went into vacation mode so fast I
love it and the one thing that had he
been to Hawaii ever he had been to
Hawaii before yeah I was going to ask is
he does he still call it Hawaii it's the
is it it's the same place okay but yeah
that's where he's been
so many years ago they went before but
like dude's got a lot more hair on his
body than me too has he always so you
don't have that to look forward to he's
had a lot more hair than this too it's
it's kind of died down it's petered out
a little bit oh that's something here's
me wearing my sunglasses I'm awake I see
that but my mouth is open so there's a
number of things that we did that I'll
tell you about but first let I mean
let's talk more about a good mythical
evening Did we tell you about it we
already told you about it we just want
to tell you some more about it uh what
else can we tell you about it
um I know that we started to plan some
of the segments
we've planned most of them and I think
that they're different maybe a notch up
from last year it's totally different
than last year but then kind of this is
totally the same but then totally fresh
no repeats no repeats
we're trying different things this year
things are going to get out of hand
things are going to get memorable
um it was a once in a lifetime
experience
that we decided to now do again and
potentially annually if you guys keep
wanting us to do it if you keep showing
up buying tickets for it we'll keep
doing it
um good mythicaleating.com now this is
available exclusively on moment house
when it streams live and uh remember you
can if you're a member of the mythical
Society mythicalsociety.com you can see
us get ready for the show which will
involve some
you know sometimes the party starts hard
for the party starts in certain things
yeah yeah and then there's a good
Mythical More you can buy that as part
of a ticket and you can get an exclusive
t-shirt like check out all the ticket
packages at Good Mythical evening.com
so we one day we decided to go to the
top of the volcano because I found out
that you can drive all the way up there
like from where we were it's like an
hour and a half drive and yeah there's a
couple of places where it gets kind of a
lot of some switchbacks and I was like
listen we're not doing the road to Hana
but we got to go to the top of the the
Haleakala
it takes me a couple of times to get it
so um we're Dr we we're driving up there
and I'm like how do you prepare the
family for this I was like they're
getting a car seat we can park well I'm
just like do they all take Ginger so
yeah we got the ginger shoes and we've
got some some Dramamine do they all get
in the front seat
because you know Chrissy's got to say in
the first season in the front seat but
then she's the queen but what the but
what are the because I mean all the kids
get car seats we rented a minivan and
then we put them on top because if you
get the if you get the wind in the face
that's a lot of times that'll help I
mean it's mainly just giving them a
little bit of that anti
uh nausea stuff and making sure that
they're not on their phones when it gets
so it worked it did work
and the other thing I was concerned
about is like is it a long hike but no
you drive up to the top and then there's
a couple places where you can just look
out now the the thing that people Rave
about and you have to get reservations
to do this is to go up at like four
o'clock you know Sunrise Sunrise you
know you're at like 10 000 feet you're
and it's you're in the middle of this
island and you can you can see you can
watch the sunrise and you can see like
all the other all these other Hawaiian
Islands
not every single one of them but I mean
I we didn't I was like we're not getting
up that early yeah so we didn't do that
you can also watch Sunset when I was
like yeah we just go if we get up there
that'll be a victory
so we drive up there
I mean it's a and we're like man there's
so many clouds what's
We're not gonna see anything but it was
so high that we went above the clouds oh
wow some and it was pretty amazing even
at the middle of the day you got
pictures of that about the clearance so
we're driving up there and you don't
have to hike too much in order to uh
you get out of the car and you're kind
of just like at an overlook
you know
and there's an observatory up there and
stuff you can see and I was like well
because I don't want I don't want to
make dad and Nana have to do a bunch of
walking and Hiking so like we get out
and we're like all right you guys can go
in the in the information center slash
Museum and then I'm gonna take this
Trail and just hike up a little bit
further to this top point so me and Lily
it was cold up there too
like I had to put on a coat
you know I'm cold natured
and then we we walk all the way up there
and then as we're coming back down here
comes Granddaddy and Nana walking up
there and they said well if we're going
to come all this way we're going to do
this I was like good Lord don't fall I
don't want to have a Rhett's Mama
breaking her ankles yeah right yeah you
don't get that free Scottish health care
when you're in Hawaii but you oh you
didn't have to pay for any of that
no I remember that yeah you don't get
that in Hawaii we did have to like get
more stuff done once you go back to the
US but I mean the Scottish part was free
how's her ankle now just as a side note
is there any residual it uh long-term
effect like when it when a thundercloud
comes up there there is like residual
pain at times
not debilitating by any means but
definitely it was a it was a setback
just one of those things it's just like
oh you know I I my ankle hurts a little
bit today kind of thing
so I don't recommend you breaking your
mom's ankle
on a vacation or your dad's or your
stepmom everything about my dad
you know I was I was watching him
closely to see my future yeah you know
because it's like I'm I'm proud of the
fact that he could do that little hike
and that he could enjoy himself on
vacation and that he could take a nap
with his mouth gaped open it's like
these are things that I can look forward
to yeah you can do that you know and
then the next morning after we get back
from Haleakala we're like sitting at the
breakfast buffet and I like
I like caught Lily's eye and then I
asked I was like Granddaddy and Nana
have you guys ever been to the top of a
volcano
and they were like no I sure would like
to go and I I was like uh that's where
we went yesterday
I was like what I was like I guess I I
didn't ask any follow-up questions I
just thought it was hilarious you didn't
say anything else I said that's where we
went yesterday and they were like oh oh
yeah you're okay you're right
did they think it was a ride
I maybe the way I asked like Soaring
Over California in
Disneyland to go to the top of a volcano
they pictured an an erupting volcano or
something Joe Versus the Volcano so it's
like it didn't really connect to like
totally dormant volcano but I'm like
yeah that's that's uh are you with me
are you
are you here for this do you
they had a good time now whether they
remembered it or not is another question
I've been to a non-dormant I remember I
remember you guys got in a huge argument
because you were hiking to it any any
sort of hiking yeah I mean boy it'll it
it there's it Jesse and I will find out
I didn't do any hiking even though I
really wanted to
no hiking
yeah I mean you you had to do you got to
plan better than we did it was a little
too last minute but yeah I mean
non-dormant volcanoes are even more fun
I know I would really love to do that
which is like a big highlight of going
to uh the Big Island
yeah if it's flowing I don't know if
it's flowing right now it was flowing
when you went though oh yeah
not like crazy not like
a river of lava going into the ocean but
just like oh there it is bubbling along
hot
eventually get into the ocean and
steaming up I don't want to say that
Maui wasn't beautiful it's just the
beaches were really the highlight and as
it turns out scuba diving is is a big
thing on Maui there's lots of
destinations well then that's why you
can really enjoy and that's what you've
been preparing for that before yeah
that's not I actually didn't know that
it kind of worked out but like yeah I
was like we're gonna go to Hawaii and
then I was like yeah let's really get
going get into gear on this like getting
certified for scuba looking forward to
the trip but as it turns out like that
is a highlight of being on Maui even
more so than Kawaii like Kauai there's
you can you know you can scuba dive uh
probably in any Hawaiian island but like
Maui is actually according to the people
we went with
um because we went on two different days
it Maui's the best of course this is
just me and Lincoln because we got
certified leading up to the trip and
this is a big part of what I was looking
forward to and you know I mean you were
living basically the White Lotus
life you know you were the dad in White
Lotus
which great show
hits and it really started to hit close
to home when yeah it's one thing to like
yeah and weren't you like we didn't
relatively close to the resort where
they actually they found out the Four
Seasons in Maui yeah we were at the
andaz resort which is like next door to
it so you were next door to the set yes
doing the same thing with your teenage
son yeah
and they had that Outrigger Canoe that
you could you could reserve and go out
on that too when uh when we did a trip a
day trip one day uh
I think yeah that was when some other
members of the family did the Outrigger
did you have an existential crisis no I
did not well The Accidental crisis was
during the luau I mean you know they had
booked one night we go to the little out
so I'll get back to the scuba diving but
the White Lotus of it all to me was
really that being at the luau and kind
of feeling this like
okay I'm paying this High ticket price
as a tourist to come here and eat your
pork and like
entertain me with your history you know
yeah it felt
imperialist it felt a little I just felt
a little uncomfortable I mean especially
thinking of the White Lotus of it all
and like it was the daughter who was
like woke and like laying into him and
the daughter's friend who was like you
know seeing the other side of it I
didn't know exactly how to feel about it
but it made but it did make you think it
made you think twice about it so you
didn't just well the lonely enjoy it the
luau was it was it was pretty
educational about like the way the way
that they're that the Pacific Islanders
and the Hawaiian settlers they would
fish and the all the Ingenuity of the
things they would do but yeah it's like
yeah it just felt
yeah I don't know what to say it felt
very American yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you felt like a
colonizer it's a good show though
because it it puts it just
it puts it out there yeah I mean it's an
excellent show for that and the music is
great too it made you have a more
difficult time enjoying your Hawaiian
vacation right mission accomplished yeah
right yeah
yeah that's all I'll say about that but
the scuba diving oh you know it's I we
planned a trip in like day three or day
four and then you know we skipped a
number of days and then went to a
different place so the the first day we
went out on a boat with a group of
people who were all scuba diving to
molokini Crater so you got this
um you can see this like strip of land
out in between our beach and uh the next
Island over Lanai and you so it's it's
half of this crater that's the one that
like the Microsoft guy owns most of it
right
uh the Oracle guy Oracle guy yep he owns
basically owns all of it it used to be
that Island used to be a dull pineapple
Farm like the whole thing and then he
bought the whole thing and then he's
there's there's one Resort on there and
then there's people who live at the top
of the island and then they all work at
the resort basically
we were actually going to stay there but
Christy didn't want to take a second
plane ride because she hates flying on
plane so much and I was like you know
what that's fine there's no I don't
think there's anything to do over there
anyway
you can like rent a Jeep and like drive
the Jeep around all over the island
which would have been fun but yeah we we
actually went close on our second scuba
diving but the first one was molokini
crater and
yeah I it was the first time for
everything except technically diving
like diving off of a boat diving with a
group like having an orientation
you know it was all like them getting
your tanks ready and everything every
everything was new but they made it
really easy and you kind of
a guy jumps in the water with you and
there was a group of like six of us
and then Lincoln and I were of course
buddies so even though you have a guide
it's really up to you like you have to
be responsible for your own safety you
can't depend on
anybody else some guide to make sure
that you're safe and to check everything
for you you got to be responsible for
yourself that's why there's so much
training and certification but then you
you learn to rely on a buddy to stay
together and to like keep an eye on each
other and communicate and and help each
other like worst case if you needed to
get air like if you run out of air
something goes wrong like they can give
you their spare air that type of stuff
and help you get back to the surface so
like Lincoln and I buddied up but we
were in a group that was like you you
get in the water and then you descend to
like 30 40 50 feet and then
on this first dive he's taking us around
on the outside of the crater and it I
mean it's just it's like flying beside a
mountain
you know you're just suspended in water
in this like and it's just a sheer I
would say it's like
a 60 degree
slope that just just goes down and it
seems like it just goes down forever
like if you just kept if you didn't
watch yourself you could just swim down
to like a like a a crazy depth
some what's the maximum depth that you
went to that we went to
um 55 feet
it's pretty deep yeah and so like on
your left side as we're like curving
around it's just the whole this whole
wall of just
underwater Mountainside and there's like
some creatures that he would point out
and stuff like that but then on the
right it's just it just goes into like
deep blue it's just
like straight out straight down it's
just like you just get this sense of
just being so small I mean like a
shark's gonna come out of the the blue
depths and a shark swam out of the blue
depths and like I would say it was 40
feet away but yeah it was like a how big
white tipped
um
shark there may be another word in there
I can't remember but like a white tip
shark I would say it was probably
um
six feet long
I was just swimming out there and they
were at a separate point I looked out
there and there was a big Ray not a
manta ray but an an eagle ray that's
what they're called
so it's like hey this is what I was this
is kind of what you hoped for you know
you see you you're swimming out there
and seeing this freaking Wildlife you're
seeing a shark you're seeing an eagle
ray just like oh how big was that
probably five feet wingspan on this
thing I mean it was again it might have
been it might have been 40 feet away
because we were saying close to the edge
and then if you he said at the end of
this thing there's a shark cleaning
station
shark yeah cleaning station it's not
where a bunch of scuba divers go around
a shark and just start scrubbing it with
brushes but it's where like little fish
would a shark would go there and get a
little yeah he knows that these little
fishes are gonna eat this stuff I don't
have them and they should like make him
all clean did you see this in action uh
we ran out of air before
uh we got to that you know everybody are
just using just me and Lincoln you know
this is our first day I've been
breathing too hard you know you're
breathing too hard well actually I
looked around and I couldn't find
Lincoln I'm like oh God we lost your
buddy where is Lincoln and they train
you like if you lose your buddy panic
yeah just just Panic just Panic just
start sucking in water
crap your pants it's over for both of
you ink and just do your the human
version of an ink which is like sharting
no it's like you're supposed if you
can't see them you look up you look down
and then you start to ascend and you
look around again and again but I just
looked up and I could see him
up there 30 feet and he was already
going up
because he was he was like very low on
air and he kind of got a little scared
and instead of swimming over and tapping
me on the shoulder and telling me
he got a little ahead of himself and he
was like oh crap I gotta get out of here
but he you know you still have to ascend
at a at a slow rate so how many how long
do approximately if you're 55 feet I
think it was I think our dive was like
36 minutes and there were probably
people who were like down there for 45
minutes no but once you realize it's
your lawn air like what's the maximum
what's the minimum amount of time that
you need in order to ascend the 60 feet
back to the surface
I should know that shouldn't I isn't
that part of like the math and stuff oh
I don't do math
yeah but you don't let it get below 500
and then there's no issue like when
you're down there at 50 or 60 feet it's
like yeah you're not gonna have any
problem it's like once you get to that
but like if you forget about it then you
I actually don't know the answer to that
don't let that happen
well you might need to pay pay attention
read the book man I bet Lincoln knows
but Lincoln what he is doing well with
this like he's not
he's enjoying it he's not scared a lot
of it was me watching him swim around
and just like getting enjoyment out of
the fact that he was enjoying it you
know the fact that I had an idea to do
something and I got him to put in the
work and then he's loving it it was one
of the highlights of the trip basically
just like white looks except you
succeeded
like you succeeded in what that that Dad
was like trying to get his son to do
something to connect with him
but not really not really exceeding but
you you've had you actually pulled it
off it worked on our account yeah yeah
the second trip we did
um we went with a different outfit we
had to drive further and then get on a
different boat that went to uh Lanai so
we're like we get to go around that
island and see that the one Resort on
the island and then how Barren it is and
how Wild it is and then is it like trees
is it all trees there's not a lot of
trees no because they they clear cut
everything for pineapple pineapples so
now it's just a it's more deserty like
the type of brush and everything on it
and our side of Maui was that way too
when you go to the other side there's
like a tremendous amount of rainfall and
it's a totally different ecosystem
probably a lot more like the Kawaii
experience I just didn't take the road
to Hana so I can't that's basically what
I've heard is that Maui has
it it it's the best combination of
everything that you could get on the
other Islands so
but you didn't go to that side so you
didn't yeah I didn't go to that side
um I think that is my my one regret
but that second dive trip was even
better than the first one to molokini
Crater because we went to what are
called the cathedrals you've got these
volcanic rock formations where
there's all these crevasses crevasse and
tunnels
we jump out of the boat and get going
those we get our we get our group
together and the first thing we did was
swim down to about 35 feet maybe 30 feet
and then I saw that some people in our
group all of a sudden they turn on
flashlights I'm like well damn I don't
have a flashlight
what this wasn't discussed
they mentioned something about
flashlight on the boat like if you have
a flashlight
um and once they said if you have a
flashlight I I don't have one
okay so we start going through a bona
fide tunnel a tunnel that ended up being
um probably from wall to wall
uh
not much more than 10 feet
how long is this 10 feet in diameter and
then I would say
it it might have been uh 25 feet in
length it opened up to more of a big
ocean yeah
yeah not one of these endless caves that
you died I could kind of no it wasn't
going down it was totally horizontal and
like
it was the first thing we went through
and I was like oh my gosh this is this
is crazy you know the the main thing
you're learning to do when you're
learning to scuba dive is like is to
regulate your buoyancy regulate your
depth in the water using your your
floatation like adding air or removing
air from it so that you know you're not
in this case scraping against the top or
the bottom of the tunnel
it was it was so much fun and then after
that we're going down into these like
other little little Archway tunnels like
swimming through all of those type of
rock formations
oh it was
it was such a payoff to the work that we
put in to get certified
I can't wait to go scuba diving again
man we're I'm I'm trying to plan a trip
now for uh me and Lincoln I asked Chase
if he wanted to go and he's the only
other person at mythical I know of who's
scuba certified to go out to the Channel
Islands yeah and and do that but there
were there were dudes with beards man
you're saying you don't want to do it
because you got this mustache no no I've
been you got to figure it out I've heard
many people say that you would
absolutely love it but I uh in a little
bit of snorkeling that I've done when I
like used the stuff that they said to
use like the silicone like stuff you
know it was just like I I need to I have
to get somebody who actually knows
what to do to tell me what to do versus
just going on the internet and
you know you I it's totally I mean you
got to figure it out like Shepherd's a
strong swimmer right yeah he would love
it
you know I'm not a strong swimmer it's
not about that but like you're so
comfortable in the water
yeah I mean I'm definitely intrigued by
it I I mean I was thinking about
um
going spearfishing with a friend that
that does that because that's more just
like put on the snorkel and hold your
breath for a long time which I can do
yeah you can do that
um no I'm definitely I'm definitely
interested in it and I think Shepherd I
know Shepherd would be into it he would
be like sure I'll do it
yeah it's
it's I mean and I wasn't I still am not
comfortable enough to like completely
enjoy myself because again everything
and taking out a boat and going with a
guide and like people giving you
orientation and all that everything's
still so new and then you get in the
water and you're like you're you're
learning how to use the dive computer
and
how to follow people but not too close
you know everything's kind of you're
figuring it out and I yeah so there was
a lot on my mind but my instructor told
me it's like after you get a certain
amount of Dives under your belt then it
becomes this total Zen
experience you stop thinking about it
well you can be you know being in the
water is totally being in the moment and
he said and when you come back out on
land you look at the world differently
you start to look uh vertically
like you we tend to work in like a
horizontal plane you know because
because we're not Birds
but he said you start to bring more of
that back into your experience on land
have you been looking up more you start
looking up more
took a walk from my house and I was like
oh look at the trees up there I wonder
if I could fly up there to him it's just
just kind of float up
it's it's don't get any ideas it's great
man that's a whole other thing is to get
those uh
um but get those backpack fans
maybe I get into that
what do you mean about oh you're talking
about a like a jet pack powered
parachute oh yeah Jesse won't let me
know she she's she's afraid I'm gonna
die this is better than that it's but
it's there's a lot more freedom and
there's not like anything it's safer
it's got to be safe it's definitely
safer we also did an ATV trip which
um was not nearly as good as the ATV
trip that like when we were in Kauai and
we went with our the boys
and we're like we're like in those quads
and like going through we went through
this like bamboo for us and we went to
this place that had a what was it
waterfall well this this was on an old
pineapple farm there's so many of them
in Maui and they were they they were
given permission to turn it since
they're not growing pineapples anymore
to reach who grows the pineapples now
they're not growing any they are or in
Lanai I don't know
I think they're all grown in a lab man
hmm But you got this so you got this ATV
course and there's like all of this
black plastic coming up
and so they stop and explain at a
certain point
there are layers upon layers of black
plastic
you see like Gardens where people plant
stuff and like to keep the weed part of
the farming keep the weeds out they'll
like poke a hole and plant something and
then they'll water underneath the
plastic so it's it it conserves water
and it it was a farming technique that
actually destroyed the Land There where
what they would do is
after a season of pineapples then they
would like till it up and then put
another layer of plastic and just do
that again and again to the point where
it's like you go 8 10 12 16 feet down
and it's just layers of plastic where
they would just decimate the land people
do so much stupid stuff I know it was so
depressing but the the cool thing about
the ATV place we went was that like
they're rehabilitating the land there's
no way you can pull out all that plastic
but what you can do is that you can
replant
um trees on top of it
and like there was a whole part that
they had never planted uh pineapples up
on the hill and so there were still a
forest up there and they said look up
there you see all the rain see all the
rain clouds above the forest
it's like the reason why they planted
pineapples here is because all of that
rain was down here
and what I didn't realize was that once
they that the forest actually it's
making the rain it makes the rain and it
it you know it draws in all the moisture
and so then when you when you cut it
down thinking oh we're going to take use
of all this moisture to make pineapples
all of a sudden the rain disappears so
they discover that the hard way
so there's a lot of Rehabilitation
that's going on
but it doesn't make for the most fun ATV
experience because the landscape was not
that dynamic
right so I between I would recommend
going on an ATV in Kauai but not on that
that part of Maui at least it just
wasn't
it just wasn't the most fun thing we've
ever done
we're just getting any good food you
haven't talked about the food yet
besides the breakfast
we ate some good fish
but you don't seem that you impressed
yeah I don't the the food wasn't a big
thing for me
you don't really like sushi nope
we ate the the kids ate some sushi
Christie ate some sushi but nah that's
not for me I mean the one thing we did
experience and dad said this was like
one of his favorite things was we went
to a place called coconutinformation.com
which if that's not the catchiest name
for something that sounds like a website
to me it sounds like a website but
there's this guy Ryan who he has this
um he has this like Outpost information
about coconuts and he's planted all
these coconuts and he just it was an
enthralling experience going our travel
agent told us to go because Guy Fieri
went there
and so you can you can see coconut
information
featured with Guy Fieri on one of his
shows on Food Network so like
after that aired we like booked well in
advance to go see Ryan and hear about
his coconuts and he gave us this whole
education on
on coconuts just like the age of the
coconut determines like what the what
the coconut milk tastes like how
fascinating is coconut information
really I we had all we had a lot of fun
you was one of your dad's favorite
things my dad said it was one of his
favorite things
okay I had a good time it was good they
put alcohol in the Coconuts no it was
just it was just information it was just
well it was and it was coconut milk and
we made we took the coconut meat and we
made these made it into noodles
we did that so it was like a little bit
of a cooking but you don't even like
coconut I don't like dried coconut on
like a cake but you know what I love
coconut water
that's what I discovered it's magical
it's got like electrolytes you
discovered coconut water on this trip no
I I drank coconut water in Thailand
when I went there the guy would hack
open a coconut and I stick a straw down
in it and drink it right it's delightful
along with some corn yeah but uh once I
got back home I started buying coconut
water it's great
a lot of electrolytes right you like
coconut water yeah we we we have it
regularly in uh in the like the outside
fridge next gotta keep it real cold
um did you
the Newton forgive me if you talked
about this song dispatch is from Myrtle
Beach but given the fact that your dad
is
um
you know into being recognized
did you meet any mythical beasts while
you two were together because that seems
like that would be a pretty cool
experience for some ethical beasts well
the the the podcast was so fresh like I
think episode one had come out while we
were there but
there were a couple of I actually I
think he was disappointed because
instead of him getting recognized I was
just getting recognized he said well hey
I'm his dad
he never said that he would just at a
couple of times he would be behind me
and I would be like at the breakfast
buffet when we exited I was like where's
Dad and then a few minutes later he
comes up he's like well there was people
back there that recognized you but you
were gone so I went over and talked to
him
he's got a picture and everything it's
like Dad you got to keep moving
sometimes yeah that's what I was
thinking he was like why didn't you stop
hey how can I you know so he he took my
leftovers basically
but yeah so I I I did get recognized so
maybe next time I'm gonna go on vacation
together
it'll be the two of you yeah getting
recognized together yeah
but I'm trying to think which was more
formative to our relationship us going
on vacation together or us making our
podcast together
the the one-two punch of both of those
things has like really opened up our
relationship but you're saying that
there's no fights no conflict no no
conflict to note
no well I think the key was yeah even
between the kids we let Lily do what she
what she wanted to do when she wanted to
do it like we gave her her space
but a lot of times kids
you know
you know the age difference between
Lincoln and Lando like I don't
I don't know I don't so Lincoln Orlando
being you know 17 and 12 right yeah
um which is essentially the same age
difference as lock and Shepard right
um
do they do like would they be like hey
Lincoln and Lando are going to do this
thing together like they're going across
the resort the two of them together like
is that a thing that happens a little
bit like a couple of times they would do
that like because kids if they don't do
that then they'll get bored yeah Lincoln
was meeting other people his age like he
was the one who was like making other
friends did he make any romantic
connections he did not make any romantic
connections if he did well he won't be
talking about it well he wouldn't tell
you anyway probably you probably
wouldn't
you don't know what he did every time
we'd walk around the resort be like
what's up like he would know people he'd
know people over here he'd know this guy
over here and then I one morning I
opened up the fridge and there's like
beers in there that we didn't I was like
where's this beer come from well my
friends my people yeah Lincoln was like
my uh my friends they were leaving and
they they offered me the beer and I was
like what he was like I didn't drink any
of it I put it in the fridge are you and
Grandad could drink it yeah he did
uh
and then what about Lando I mean because
at that age like I'll talk I'm talking
about my vacation next week but like
Shepard being by himself essentially
with us as a 13 year old there's a you
know yeah Lando needed a little bit of a
boredom thing that that that was one of
the factors like Lando got a little
bored
you know I think once you get to be
uh a teenager
you can Retreat into your phone a little
bit and you kind of want to watch your
shows and just being
be on your own
or make your own friends but yeah so
it's like Lando is a kind of a a tough
age where it was like
let's do something together
so it's like all right let's go
snorkeling let's play we had a corn hole
set out there we did some stuff like
that so like
you know kept them engaged and I think
that's why like the nine days of it all
was like good
versus it pushing it too far
or like going to a second location
yeah which would have been way too much
but the injury I forgot to tell you
about the injury
uh dad normally throws Nana under the
bus on dispatches because she he's
always dishing some dirt but I guess
I'll have to do this one because he
didn't talk about and she was putting
her her leg up on the sink in order to I
think to shave her leg or something and
she like
she fell over and hit her hit her like
her Shin like super hard and like made
up got a big old welp and I was I was
like oh is this the is this it this is
like this is like day two of vacation
I'm like oh man is she going to be able
to walk I think I think she was in a lot
of pain but she didn't want to she kind
of she was a trooper she just kind of
went along with it we iced it and then
she was somebody walking she was okay
but she so there was no break but that
that was the injury I was referring to
was that but she was okay after that she
was able to like walk around she was
able to walk around but I think she for
the next day she was in a lot of pain
and speaking of pain I think one and you
know what this can be my recommendation
because I think this is my wreck this
week when you're going on a beach
vacation and you want to do a little spa
treatment
especially if you're like me and you
want to get a massage like I well in
advance I was like I'm gonna book a
massage me and Christy gonna do a
massage I'm gonna give Dad and Nancy a
massage they're gonna love it like I was
we did it on if you're gonna do that on
a beach vacation do it on day one or day
two don't even wait to day three or day
four because what's gonna happen is
you're gonna get sunburned and then
you're gonna have this like really nice
spa treatment that you're gonna it's
gonna turn into torture like I didn't
get sunburned but Christy did even my
dad got sunburned I couldn't believe it
I was like they got sunburned
you're on day one really when my dad's
sitting out there with his mouth gaped
open just just drinking up to I mean
this is like vacation etiquette I know
like you got a sunscreen up son I know
but like and Lincoln had never gotten
sunburned in his life apparently because
he was asking me well Dad what what's
what's gonna happen I was like You're
Gonna Hurt son
You're Gonna Hurt Now I didn't get him a
massage so he didn't have to worry about
it but like he that the third morning he
was like how'd you sleep he was like I
couldn't sleep
everywhere I turn I was like yeah you
got sunburned well he learned a lesson
and then whenever later on in the week
like towards the end of the vacation is
when it's like he wasn't in pain anymore
but it started to peel and he was like
Dad am I going to die what will it grow
back what's gonna happen just one of the
seven layers of skin that will never
grow back yeah I was like dude you'll be
fine but this is the this is the best
way to learn a lesson but like even
Christy with all her years of like yeah
knowing how to like I was like man you
just you just
totally put your whole massage
in Jeopardy how did it work out
she had to get one of those like oh
barely touch me massages oh really yeah
oh but the guy but you don't pay it by
the pressure you pay by the time that's
right you know what I'm saying so I'm
like Hey listen that's why I'm I was
telling y'all to slather up
but I think the key is
if you're getting a massage on a beach
vacation get it right when you get there
or just wear sunscreen or get it I mean
if you got to work that base tan you can
do it after that
so again it was a great trip honestly I
feel like
not a lot of Sensational stuff to report
I think that kind of wraps it up for me
here with my Maui trip but I think the
best vacations maybe they don't make for
the best podcast I don't know I don't
know well even Keel we'll find out next
week because my vacation sucked oh yeah
I think that'll make it that'll make for
an interesting podcast yeah I
legitimately at one point said
I hate this vacation wow yeah in front
of my whole family uh so we can talk
about uh it's a good example we can we
can talk about how I how I got to that
point see through a tantrum maybe maybe
my dad should have been on your vacation
did like so you'd have been so you
wouldn't have thrown a tantrum
you hated it uh actually dude I'm sorry
uh no I it uh let me just say that
there were some circumstances which I
will get into next week that made it not
as enjoyable as it could and there was a
moment in which I said that
uh but there were some highlights that I
think ultimately maybe redeemed it at
least to some degree I'm excited to talk
about it
uh but it definitely was not one of my
best vacations better to have a good
story and a good time yeah well I've got
that
but I had a good time wish you were
there man
but it's okay that you weren't it seems
like you need to have a campy vacation
you can't be everywhere although I I
mean how many times were you asked
where's Rhett because
I got asked where is Link at least 10
times over the past you know over the
course of two weeks oh yeah yeah every
time I got recognized Where's link all
right yeah he's probably having a better
time than me like top of the volcano it
was a it was a big group from Kansas who
who they were taking a cruise from
across every Hawaiian island
and and they said that they were when
they they were freaking out when they
saw me at the top of the volcano and
they were like we were listening to I'm
on vacation on repeat as a family and
right right before this and now I'm
seeing you and they're like where's
Rhett and I was like he's coming up the
mountain like I that's what I would tell
people he's right behind me just look
out for it people kept people every time
people saw me and they would ask I made
them start they would they spent the
rest of the day looking for you you
didn't tell me you're you're pulling
their legs just a dumb question I'm like
he's not automatically here I always
just say I don't know I don't I don't
know I don't have he's coming up you
want me to bring up my friends come
around the mountain when he comes
all right we'll be coming around the
mountain next week so wreck can tell you
about the worst vacation yeah he's ever
had maybe not that
your crappy vacation
hey
red the keeper kimchi and kombucha I
have a name for you it is the fermented
cave that's it they're all fermented
fermented caves we're good to go did I
mention that my name was cam from
Riverside I'm sorry if I get that have a
good one hi this is John uh from San
Diego and you mentioned your 3K diet
um might have a better name for you
um since uh Kiefer is a kind of a yogurt
you can just say YKK and even better yet
you can call it the Y2K diet
um hope you have a good one and uh I'll
keep listening thanks hey y'all I'm just
listening to an ear biscuit
and you guys are talking about having
keeper
lovingkeeper my name is keeper
and I'm very confused and thrown off
flattered but confused and thrown off
have a good one y'all to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]